so you mentioned to me the book the
100-year marathon by Michael
Pillsbury uh when we discussed
China and uh I've gotten a chance to
read parts of it and i' highly recommend
people read it because there's a few
it's a definitely an eye openening
perspective I don't know if I agree with
all of it I don't know if you agree with
all of it but it certainly opens it
gives a very intense perspective on
China and you said it was instructive to
how you thought how Donald Trump thought
about
China uh can you describe the main
thesis of the book and maybe with the
hopeful view how it's possible to have a
trajectory of these two superpowers
working together in the 21st
century uh versus fighting against each
other perfect so um it's a very very big
book and I I I think it's a book
definitely worth reading Michael is uh
is is is tremendous he speaks fluent uh
Mandarin in and so he he spent a lot of
time researching to do the book so I
highly recommend it to everyone and it
was considered more of a fringe
perspective uh in 2016 but it really I
think came to represent the underpinning
of what uh the collective thought was of
the Trump
Administration and um and maybe you
could argue that it was even more
cynical the the whole thesis of the book
was that China from 1949 to 2049 was
working to reclaim their position as the
global leader right so you the the
Chinese Empire um you know one of the
things I don't know if it's from this
book or a different book that I read
that spoke about how in the late 1700s
basically the Emperor of China was
offered some of the industrial
capability from England which was
basically now becoming an industrial uh
the Industrial Revolution and basically
no we're fine we're the great Chinese
Empire we don't we don't need any of
these things we're we're better than
that and by rejecting that the rest of
the world got stronger China remained
weaker uh then you had the the the the
Opium War Wars you know the the Chinese
had big opium problems through all the
trade back and forth and then China from
about 1840 to to 1940 at 100 years where
they really after all these uh treaties
were really a second class country and
so then you have the people's Revolution
that comes in and he talks about how
China very strategically as a very very
poor country um you know would fight
their way back and and build Brick by
Brick and you know he propers in the
book that Nixon didn't go to China and
open China China that actually went to
Nixon and was able to use Nixon in order
to open up then they talk about how
under Carter they were able to get the
US to contribute to a lot of their uh
they were able to kind of start
borrowing the us knowhow from our
University Systems from our medical from
our science from our research and the
whole notion that was the conventional
thinking of American leaders was that
the more we helped China Advance the
more they would become a free market
economy and it was a great Market the
only difference was was that they
weren't allowing us access they were
making our companies basically give them
all of their technical knowledge they
were stealing our intellectual property
uh they were doing Espionage to to steal
a lot of the patents they were just
ignoring our patents and they weren't
following any of the rules of
international trade then they started
becoming the world's manufacturing Hub
they basically became the world's
Factory and then they started this whole
initiative called the belt and Road
initiative in order to start locking in
their lines of tra they were buying up
all the ports everywhere they were
building Railways thinking how do we we
lock in our distrib ution so that we can
maintain the dominance as the world's
Global Factory and so it was a brilliant
long-term plan that they were doing and
by raising awareness by putting the
tariffs Trump slowed them down a lot um
the real question is is if they actually
did achieve this full objective of
becoming the world uh dominant country
what they would have done with it
whether they would have been nefarious
or not I think from my perspective even
with some of the divisions and issues we
have now in America I still would rather
an American Le World daughter than a
Chinese Le World daughter um but the
notion was is that they were playing a
very Zero Sum game and really going to
be the dominant leader in this new world
order so um so that really framed the
perspective and it wasn't necessarily
you know people ask me was was and the
Chinese were always fearing is Trump
trying to stop our rise right and you
have a great book also by Graham Allison
that he writes about you know are we
destined for war between us and China
and he goes through different historical
times where you have a power and a
rising superpower and I think you know
more than half the time it ends up
leading to war so the question is is
what's going to happen here and I I do
think that Trump's perspective and this
is my interpretation because everything
was always tactical dayto day and you
know he was unpredictable to the Chinese
which they couldn't deal with and he was
unpredictable even to his team sometimes
because he was playing it day by day and
issue by issue and always changing and
adjusting which is how an entrepreneur
thinks he respected the job they did by
building their country they moved 300
million people out of poverty into the
middle class they did it at the expense
of a lot of other countries throughout
the world especially America but Trump
says look stupid politicians made deals
I respect China for doing what they did
but what I want to do is I want to
change the Paradigm so that for the next
20 years we can maintain our advantage
over them we can maintain our
competitive Dynamic and you know his
General view was that America is the
best private sector in the world we have
a lot of the best mindes uh in the world
and if we can just have a Level Playing
Field with set rules then America should
be able to outperform and so that's
really what we were trying to do we were
trying to kind of get rid of some of
their stap subsidies get rid of make
them follow some of these International
rules of trade and um and not allowing
them to do predatory um Investments That
Then undercut different industries that
we had so that they can have global
market dominance or monopolies on
different Industries and then have
pricing power but but also um you know
geopolitical power so like one of the
examples that people talk about now is
China for the last 20 years was very
Advanced on seeing this electrification
trend they went they they they
subsidized solar panels a lot of the
American solar panel players were put
out of business so now I think it's like
90 plus% of solar panels in the world
are manufactured in China then all the
rare earth that you need in order to
make these solar panels and to make
these electric vehicles China's bought
up most of them and a lot of the
refining capacities in China so thinking
through strategically how do we create
an even playing field so that we're not
at the mercy of them and how you can
have a rules-based world order that was
really kind of the thought of what we
were trying to work
towards